[Musique]
j'ai passé l'après-midi du 1er mai
dernier à mon bureau le directeur de
cabinet m'a tenu informé du déroulement
des manifestations et des opérations de
maintien de l'ordre
je rappelle que ces manifestations se
sont révélés d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle au regard des violences
commises des commerces saccagés des
dégradations constatées et d un perte
interpellations auxquelles les forces de
l'ordre ont procédé
je veux saisir cette occasion pour
saluer l'engagement sans faille des
forces de l'ordre et le
professionnalisme dont elles ont fait
preuve au cours de ces événements la
question des événements de la place de
la contrescarpe now n'a à aucun moment
été mentionné j'ai été informé le
lendemain le 2 mai dans la matinée par
le conseiller en charge notamment des
réseaux sociaux et le directeur de
cabinet de la publication sous les
réseaux sociaux d'une vidéo dans
laquelle un individu qui sa part s
apparenter à monsieur benalla se livrer
à des actes inappropriés et choquants
dans le cadre des opérations de maintien
de l'ordre sur la place de la
contrescarpe à ce moment le directeur de
cabinet mme indique qu'il a d'ores et
déjà convoqué l'intéressé qui a reconnu
sa présence sur les lieux et sa
participation des interprétations je
m'assure que le directeur de cabinet a
bien vérifié auprès de la préfecture de
police et du cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur de la réalité des faits
retracé dans la vidéo et qu'ils sont
bien la forme nous refaisons le point en
fin de journée
constatant que les faits sont bien
avérée le directeur de cabinet m'informe
de son intention d'appliquer une
sanction disciplinaire sans délai ce qui
me semble totalement approprié nous nous
reparlons le lendemain et le directeur
de cabinet ma forme de la sanction
qu'ils entendent notifié à l'agent et
donc il vous a parlé hier la suspension
de quinze jours avec votre salaire la
modification des responsabilités
confiées
l'intéressé la notification portée au
dossier l'indication que tout nouveau
comportement fautif entraînerait un
licenciement qu'ils aient lieu par la
suite
compte tenu des éléments portés à notre
connaissance à ce moment là la sanction
apparaît proportionnée au bout du compte
la sanction a été décidée dès le jour de
la découverte des faits est notifiée à
l'intéressé
dès le lendemain j'ajoute un point
compte tenu de l'audition du directeur
de cabinet patrick strzoda hier devant
vous et devant les députés de celle du
commandant militaire du palais de
l'elysée génial bio farina et du chef du
gspr le colonel lavergne
je pense j'espère que vous avez été
rassuré sur le fait qu'il n'existe pas à
l'elysée de police parallèle que nous
n'employons pas de vigiles privés pour
protéger le chef de l'état et que
monsieur benalla n'a jamais été en
charge de la protection du président de
la république
avant toute chose je tiens à redire que
j'étais personnellement choqué par ces
images et je ne doute pas que chacune et
chacun ici l'ont été tout autant je
condamne une nouvelle fois les actes
auxquels se sont livrés messieurs
alexandre benalla et vincent kraz le 1er
mai dernier
ils sont contraires aux valeurs portées
par notre république par le mouvement
politique que je préside
mon objectif monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs est clair vous
apporter tous les éléments dont j'ai eu
et j'ai connaissance en lien avec cette
journée du 1er mai tout d'abord si je
m'exprime devant vous aujourd'hui c'est
dans ma qualité de délégué général de la
république en marche fonctions que
j'assume depuis mon élection le 18
novembre 2017
compte tenu du fait voulait rappeler
monsieur le président qu'un salarié de
la république en marche est impliqué en
tant que délégué général je suis le
représentant légal toujours depuis le 18
novembre 2007 de l'association la
république en marche mais également
l'employeur de tous les salariés du
mouvement c'est dans ce cadre que je
souhaite vous faire part des faits tels
que je les ai vécus le 2 mai
une vidéo tournée la veille a été très
largement diffusés sur les réseaux
sociaux où elle a été vue plus de 100
mille fois plusieurs salariés de la
république en marche mon vue et ont été
stupéfaits dit reconnaître un de leurs
collègues
en l'occurrence vincent kra ce qu'ils
connaissent bien puisqu'il est l'un des
agents en charge de l'accueil de la
sécurité du siège de la république en
marche
ils ont également reconnu pour certains
d'entre eux alexandre benalla que
certains avaient pu croiser durant la
campagne présidentielle
j'ai été informé ce même jour le 2 mai
aux alentours de 18 heures alertée j'ai
alors visionner sur mon téléphone cette
vidéo présente dans les locaux de la
république en marche à cette heure là
j'y arrivais j'ai souhaité voir vincent
kraz vers 18h15 en présence de mon
directeur de cabinet françois blouvac et
du responsable sécurité et sûreté le
supérieur hiérarchique de vincent grass
pierre-yves barratier immédiatement pour
lui demander des explications sur ce que
cette vidéo révélée pour information
vincent graze occupe depuis le 1er
juillet 2010 est un poste de responsable
adjoint sûreté sécurité au sein des
effectifs de la république en marche
en tant que non cadres et sous
l'autorité d'un chef de sécurité dans un
service de huit personnes qui a
notamment la charge de l'accueil la
surveillance des locaux de l'association
je tiens à votre disposition de ceux
présents madame monsieur le
co-rapporteur l'organigramme de ce
service lors de cet entretien vincent
kraz indiqué avoir agi en tant que
gendarme réserviste le premier mais à la
demande expresse d'alexandre benalla
avec il a indiqué être en contact dans
le cadre d'opérations réalisées elles
aussi en tant que gendarme réserviste
vincent kraz malheur informé qu'il était
chef d'escadron gendarme de réserve
depuis 1996 rattaché à l'elysée dans un
cadre extra professionnelles il a
ensuite confirmé que les faits étaient
intervenus en dehors de son temps de
travail la réplique en marche
en dehors de toute information de sa
hiérarchie qui n'en avait pas rendu
compte
c'est d'ailleurs dans ce cadre je cite
ouvrez les guillemets gendarmes
réservistes par ailleurs employé de la
réplique en marche qu'il est identifié
par monsieur bruno roger petit porte
parole de la république de la présence
de la république
pour information cet entretien n'a duré
que quelques minutes puisque je
présidais un bureau exécutif à 18h30
devant effectuer le
demain déplacement de trois jours dont
l'eure et loir du 3 au 5 mai j'ai
demandé à mon directeur de cabinet
françois blouvac et aux supérieurs
hiérarchiques directs de vincent crasse
pierre-yves barratier de le recevoir
le 3 mai le lendemain pour définir les
suites à donner ainsi bien que ces faits
se soient déroulés hors de son cadre de
travail et la république en marche c'est
j'ai souhaité le sanctionner parce que
je considère grave ce qui s'est passé
j'en ai fait indique avait cinq races
que d'une part son comportement lors du
1er mai est en total décalage avec
l'attitude attendu des salariés de la
république en marche et notamment ceux
chargés de l'accueil de la sécurité du
mouvement y compris en dehors de leur
temps de travail et d'autre part qu'une
telle attitude porter atteinte à l'image
du mouvement qui l'emploie dans la
mesure où les faits se sont déroulés
alors que vincent kra zoom avait indiqué
qu'il intervenait en tant que réserviste
à la demande de monsieur benalla j'ai
souhaité prendre la tâche du directeur
de cabinet de la présidence de la
république pour connaître les suites à
donner et que la sanction infligée à
monsieur kraz soient liées à celles
retenues à l'encontre de monsieur
benalla un échange a eu lieu entre mon
directeur de cabinet et le directeur de
cabinet de la présidence de la
république à ce sujet et c'est sur la
base de cet échange que j'ai donc
notifiée le 3 mai par courrier à vincent
kraz la sanction de suspension de quinze
jours du 4 au 18 mai inclus depuis
l'ouverture de l'enquêté judiciaire j'ai
adressé vendredi 20 juillet vincent
crachin croyait lui indiquant que la
réplique en marche lancé une procédure
de licenciement à son encontre fondés
sur le trouble objectif au
fonctionnement de l'association et
l'atteinte portée à son image
aujourd'hui sur la base du rapport
établi par l'inspection générale de la
police nationale
j'ai pu constater qu'outre la faute
monsieur kraz a ajouté le mensonge
puisqu'il n'était pas ni présents ce
jour en tant que gendarme réserviste ne
bénéficier d'aucune autorisation pour
être présents monsieur le ministre
d'état nous avons découvert la sphère
benalla grâce à la vidéo protection les
images de la vidéo protection de paris
et d'une vidéo amateur on nous apparaît
dans les auditions précédentes de
l'existence de photos et de vidéos de
crs qui pourrait s'expliquer puisqu'il
était dans une position délicate place
de la contrescarpe nous avons d'abord
découvert
monsieur alexandre benalla nous avons
ensuite découvert le commando bénin
avec monsieur vincent kraz on nous parle
maintenant d'un accompagnant monsieur
misère ce qui encadre en en officiel
est-ce que ses photos et ses vidéos
vont-ils vente elle nous fait
redécouvrir pardon d'autres
protagonistes sur les lieux est-ce que
vous avez connaissance de ces photos et
que nous font-elles visionner et pour
finir je vous demanderais s'il existe
une milice privée au sein de l'elysée
or gspr merci chers collègues aussi de
votre concision monsieur le ministre
n'est pas fait pour ce qui concerne
monsieur misère ce qu'est un de ses
supérieurs hiérarchiques lui demande
d'accompagner monsieur benalla qu'il
croyait à créditer fâché pop qu'il
croyait à créditer je pense mais l'anc
est encore le montrera pour participer à
une opération de maintien de l'ordre
comme observateurs
beaucoup de députés de journalistes
participent à des opérations comme
observateurs elles sont strictement
encadrées le préfet de police l'a
rappelé hier ils souhaitaient que ce
soit elle l'a rappelé à ces cas son
autorisation personnels qu'ils soient
donnés
parce que cela engage effectivement sa
responsabilité
merci beaucoup monsieur mise d'état
madame jacky d'euromédis est ce qui va
sortir
compte tenu des deux ce qui se passe ou
agents découvrent chaque jour sur les
personnalités
je lis les journaux comme vous et il ya
toute une partie de l'histoire de
monsieur benalla que franchement je
découvre de plus en plus je redis que
c'est le 2 mai dans la matinée autour de
10h 10h15 que j'ai été alertée par un
appel téléphonique venant du palais de
l'elysée sur ce que mon interlocuteur me
désigne affaires benalla et selon la
formule je suis très étonné je ne
comprends pas je lui donne
de quoi il s'agit il n'explique les
choses l'existence de cette vidéo
j'ai joué assez vite le cabinet du
ministre de l'intérieur qui m'a indiqué
être déjà informé être en liaison avec
l'elysée
j'ai demandé évidemment mes
collaborateurs de trouver très vite
cette vidéo nous l'avons regardé
ensemble sur un grand écran dans le
bureau de mon directeur de cabinet jeudi
un grand écran parce que sur un
téléphone portable c'était petit et puis
sur le grand écran peut-être
pourrions-nous reconnaître monsieur
monsieur benalla ce qui n'était pas du
tout évident et ça ça se passe donc le
le 2 mai au matin j'ai eu contact aussi
après avoir prévenu le cabinet du
ministre de nouveau avec le palais de
l'elysée pour expliquer les choses
telles que je les avais vus à l'écran et
il était clair pour moi que le dossier
était pris en compte par ce que
j'appelle l'autorité hiérarchique
monsieur benalla était sous la
responsabilité de l'autorité
hiérarchique du directeur de cabinet de
la présidence et non pas de moi même mes
réactions en interne pour faire vite je
demande immédiatement à la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation
bref pourquoi et comment il était là
sachant que j'avais été très étonné la
veille au soir de croiser monsieur
benalla dans la salle de commandement où
j'avais accueilli deux ministres mais
c'est en faisant le tour vous n'êtes là
étonné moi je fais tu es sur le terrain
voilà la réponse que j'ai eu et très
vite le direct immédiatement le
directeur de l'ordre public et de la
circulation m'a dit je n'étais pas
informé du fait que monsieur benalla
était ce jour là dans nos rangs y mène
son enquête interne qui fait apparaître
le niveau d'organisation de la venue de
monsieur benalla autorisation réponse à
sollicitations je ne sais pas les
enquêtes en cours au plan judiciaire le
diront peut-être
c'est pourquoi je dis le niveau
d'organisation et d'accueil au niveau
d'un contrôleur général chef d'état
major adjoint qui s'appelle monsieur
simoneau
donc il y a eu du côté de l'elysée
monsieur patrick strzoda mon collègue
ami patrick strzoda l'a dit
l'autorisation donnée par le cabinet du
président de la république
monsieur ménal à devenir le 1er mai sur
le territoire de la préfecture de police
à la préfecture de police a eu lieu au
niveau d'un contrôleur général
l'organisation de sa venue le directeur
adjoint de l'ordre public
le directeur de l'ordre public n'était
pas informé le préfet de police
encore moins voilà exactement comment
les choses se sont se sont passées pour
la connaissance de ceux de ce
déplacement
j'ai dans le menu précisé l'enchaînement
de de ces informations successives
je dois répéter que monsieur benalla
n'était pas chargée d'assurer
personnellement la sécurité rapprochée
du président la république
qu'effectivement il soit à proximité du
président de la république il faut
placer cette présence dans sa mission de
coordination de plusieurs services
lorsque le président la république dit
je vais changer mon programme je vais
aller saluer les personnes qui sont là
bas sur la place plutôt que d'aller dans
l'équipement public que je doit
inaugurer gérer un peu plus tard eh bien
il le dit à qui il le disait à monsieur
benalla pour que celui-ci répercute ce
changement de programme au cortège qu'il
faut déplacer le cortège au dispositif
de sécurité qu'il faut redéployer
voilà donc c'est vrai que il y à des
photographies qui montre que comme vous
dites
ils sont à 20 centimètres l'un de
l'autre mais on ne voit que ses
photographies mais lorsque monsieur
benalla devait courir à l'autre bout
d'une place pour s'assurer que le
président de la république tout à venir
serrer des mains en toute sécurité
non on voit pas les photos ce directeur
et nous attendons des explications à oui
elles sont pour nous un peu contre
intuitive parce qu'effectivement nous
voyons ce collaborateur et dans de
nombreuses circonstances
et dans une attitude une posture qui
évoque quand même très fortement celle
d'un garde du corps et nous avons cru
comprendre que c'est bien la fonction
qu'ils avaient occupée pendant la
campagne présidentielle et nous pouvons
faire l'hypothèse peut être fausse que
le lien de confiance qui s'était établi
à cette occasion n'a pas été rompue
après l'élection du président de la
république que celui ci s'en est
largement remis pour sa protection
rapprochée à un jeune collaborateur dont
il avait éprouvé les talents ces salles
hypothèse oui que vous que vous ne
demandez pas complètement mais vous
essayez de re situer l'action de ce
collaborateur dans un cadre plus formel
plus organisés mais ce que la réalité on
nous a beaucoup parlé des réalités de la
vie n'est pas plutôt celle que je décris
monsieur le président je ne peux pas
contester qu'il ya de nombreuses
photographies qui montre cette proximité
mais je je je prends le pari de bras
vous qu'il existe autant de
photographies mais qu'elles ne sont pas
publiées qui montre que le chef de
cabinet dans cette position que
l'adjoint au chef de cabinet dans cette
position seulement évidemment il
ils ont la chance de ne pas être effacé
cabinet porte il une arme at il des
oreillettes pour s'exprimer il est un
système de communication une boucle mais
il n'est pas une batterie de sécurité
ils n'assurent pas la sécurité
rapprochée la callas comment dire il
n'est pas garde du corps du président de
la république monsieur benalla ne
portait jamais d'armes lorsque il était
dans un déplacement public du président
de la république monsieur benalla a été
recruté en qualité d'agent contractuel
c'est un contrat de droit public et donc
pour la sanction nous avons
effectivement fait application du décret
de 1986 qui prévoient l'échelle des
sanctions vous l'avez rappelé madame la
sénatrice l'avertissement l'exclusion
temporaire et le licenciement
donc là la sanction de suspension de
quinze jours en fait c'est une exclusion
temporaire
kiki a été qui a été prononcée qui a été
prononcée le conseil de discipline n'a
pas été saisie parce que nous n'avons
pas de conseils de discipline dans les
services de l'elysée est gelée indiqué
ce qui a primé dans dans notre décision
c'était la rapidité prendre une sanction
immédiate adaptée et proportionnée
ce qui a été fait la première question
c'était à oui tout à fait alors excusez
moi je vais monsieur benalla a touché
pour le mois de mai son salaire intégral
en revanche en revanche les 15 jours de
suspension se feront l'objet d'une
retenue sur les droits à congés qu'ils
avaient en reliquat au titre de l'année
il arriva il a de très nombreux jours de
congés auquel il a droit au titre de
l'année 2010 est et dans son solde avant
licenciement
c'est congé nous serons pas payer mes
chers collègues la réponse de monsieur
le directeur a le mérite de la franchise
je crois qu'il faut le lui reconnaître
selon les éléments en ma possession il
semblerait manifestement qu'au sein du
gspr j'insiste bien sur le semblerait
avec le conditionnel qui s'imposent
qu'effectivement au sein du j'espère
nous avions un groupe un groupe de 2,2
de personnel or police et or jean namory
dans et hors du champ de la mission
régalienne de sécurité qui doit être
celle du gsp à la protection du
président des pluies et de son épouse
qui en l'occurrence était d'aider des
civils des privés et c'est bien pour ça
que j'ai employé depuis le début depuis
jeudi dernier jean pas le terme de
barbouzes parce que ces gens là n'ont
aucune habilitation
ce ne sont ni plus ni moins que sans que
ce soit péjoratif si j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les métiers de la sécurité
privée
mais ce sont des vigiles qui était
employé aujourd'hui manifestement par
monsieur benalla dans le cadre de la
protection de la présidence de la
république
oui effectivement monsieur le secrétaire
général cette information que vous ne
donnez est extrêmement importante est ce
que vous êtes en mesure de la source et
je vais la source et moi j'ai les
renseignements que j'ai c'est bien
évidemment à travers nos réseaux de
délégués au sein du service de
protection des hautes personnalités du
sphp et bien évidemment par part est
fait je dirais sur le gspr les éléments
que j'ai eus m'ont été rapportés
effectivement par mes représentants
locaux qui m'ont dit effectivement qui
m'ont affirmé qu'ils avaient des groupes
de 2,2 privé qu'il travaillait en
l'occurrence avec monsieur benalla et
qui est provoqué justement détention
avéré entre eux les fonctions de police
et monsieur b nana et ses comparses qui
en l'occurrence et ça serait d'ailleurs
un des motifs de la réorganisation du
gspr dans la perspective de la
protection du fort de brégançon pendant
les vacances du président monsieur le
secrétaire général est ce que vos
correspondants vous vous aurez indiqué
le nombre de vies
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas le nombre précis
monsieur le président mais on peut s'en
enquérir et je ne manquerai pas de
porter à votre connaissance si vous me
permettez de tels renseignements et je
ne vous le permet pas je vous le demande
il a reçu monsieur le président monsieur
chauvette vous voulez apporter des
précisions je voulais simplement
apporter une précision mais qui est qui
doit être évidente à mon sens pour tout
le monde sait que compte tenu de la
sensibilité de cette affaire et de
l'endroit où était affecté entre
guillemets monsieur benalla c'est à dire
ni plus ni moins dans la proximité du
président de la république il arborait
systématiquement sa carte
à n'importe quel fonctionnaire qui est
rencontraient du cabinet donc de
l'elysée il est bien évident que faire
parler nos collègues et je répond
directement à la question précédemment
que ce soit les gars des gradés et
gardiens de la paix mais aussi que la
moyenne est rare chez les officiers les
commissaires personne n'allait se
répandre sur des travers qui aurait pu
être effectués et semble-t-il puisque
secrétaire général vient d'annoncer qu
effectivement les langues se délient on
apprend qu'il ya eu plusieurs quoi
qu'ils n'étaient pas de même niveau
certes mais qui à la fois faisait état
d' altercation avec les forces de police
et de gendarmerie sur certains maintien
de l'ordre
roux il souhaitait prendre la tête de
dispositifs ou détourné l'action de la
police nationale sur certaines
interventions et qui plus est pour ceux
qui éventuellement pouvait trouver ça
totalement anormal et éventuellement le
faire savoir
et bien il y avait effectivement cette
carte qu'il présentait qu'il arborait
que là pour le coup c'était plus
difficile à faire savoir
eu égard aux déroulements de carrière
que vous pouvez bien comprendre monsieur
benalla était à la chefferie cabinet il
officie dans toutes ses missions sous
l'autorité du chef de cabinet monsieur
françois xavier loches monsieur
alexandre benalla était chargé de
mission adjoint au chef de cabinet je
précise que dans la chefferie cabinet il
y a le chef de cabinet il ya le chef
adjoint de cabinet qui sont nommés au
journal officiel
et il ya deux chargés de mission adjoint
au chef de cabinet dont faisait partie
monsieur benalla ses missions je vais je
vais laisser quand c'est une manière
temporelle ça va vous donner des
éclairages sur quels étaient ses
missions et ses relations avec le
j'espère jusqu'au 1er mai 2018
ces missions étaient triples la plus
importante mission c'était la
participation à l'organisation des
déplacements officiels du président de
la république sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet à ce titre il assuré la
coordination des services qui concourt à
l'organisation du déplacement
conformément au programme qui sont
arrêtés par le chef de cabinet quand on
parle de coordination des services dans
ces services là il y a le j'espère mais
il n'y a pas seulement le j'espère il ya
tous les services qui concourent à la
sécurité et les autres services qui
concourent au déplacement parmi ceux qui
concourent à la sécurité
vous avez les services locaux bien
évidemment compétences avec la
professeure de prise sur l'agglomération
parisienne
ça va être les services de police ou de
gendarmerie
en département province et les autres
services du palais c'est par exemple
service de l'intendance le service de
l'udinese est le service presse en fait
la chefferie cabinet c'est le chef
d'orchestre des déplacements du
président république monsieur benalla
officier toujours sous l'autorité du
chef de cabinet ça veut dire que par
exemple avec les autres services faisant
en sorte effectivement que le podium
pour président soit bien installé en
zinc l'audiovisuel que le pupitre soit
bien là que les les élus soient bien
l'accueil et c'est que la presse soit
bien là quand il fallait que la presse
soit là voilà l'ensemble de ce que vous
avez connu
vous connaissez dans les départements
dans lesquels vous êtes à ce titre étant
le chef d'orchestre il n'avait aucune
autorité directe sur les services de
sécurité je connais monsieur benalla
pour l'avoir croisé depuis la prise de
fonction le 28 août dernier lors de
déplacements ou de cérémonies auxquelles
participait le président de la
république et auquel j'étais convié jeu
l'identifier clairement comme un
collaborateur du chef de cabinet de la
présidence de la république dont l'une
des missions centrale habituelle d'un
cabinet est d'organiser ses déplacements
ou ces cérémonies officielles
il était donc tout à fait naturel qu'ils
soient présents dans ces circonstances
une dizaine de fois pour ce qui me
concerne la dernière dans la tribune
officielle du 14 juillet au cours de
kate desquels je n'ai jamais remarqué de
sa part une attitude déplacée ou qu'ils
me soient apparus intrusive
je n'ai jamais eu à échanger avec lui
d'autres propos que de courtoise
salutations je n'ai pas le souvenir
d'avoir participé à des réunions travail
en sa présence
il faut dire que mes contacts avec la
présidence de la république sont rares
ces relations étant normalement réservé
au cabinet du ministre qui au besoin me
sollicite lorsque des commandes
techniques sont exprimées par la
présidence en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement les événements de la
place de la contrescarpe du 1er mai il
m'apparaît important de vous décrire
rapidement l'organisation des opérations
de maintien de l'ordre en france
sur l'ensemble du territoire national à
paris comme ailleurs le préfet
territorialement compétent à la pleine
responsabilité de la gestion de l'ordre
public
c'est sous son autorité que sont
organisées les dispositifs opérationnels
qui seront mis en oeuvre sur le terrain
par les forces de police ou de
gendarmerie parfois combinées
mon rôle consiste mon rôle de directeur
général de la police nationale consiste
donc à fournir aux préfets préfets de
police compris les forces mobiles
nécessaires au service d'ordre qu'il
prévoit selon les renseignements dont je
dispose sur le contexte de l'événement à
gérer et en fonction des forces
disponibles qu'elles appartiennent à la
police les crs ou à la gendarmerie
nationale des escadrons de gendarmerie
mobile pour le 1er mai ce sont 15 forces
mobiles de la réserve nationale dix crs
et cinq escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
que j'ai mis à disposition du préfet de
police
s'ajoutant aux huit crs qui constitue l'
enveloppe parisienne permanente dont il
dispose soit un total de 23 unités
s'ajoutant elle même aux forces
territoriale de la préfecture et je vous
pose une première question
n'y voyez pas de piège même si elle a
évidemment une dimension politique
importante pour nous mais je crois
légitime
les faits remontent au 1er mai le
ministre de l'intérieur le préfet de
police le directeur de cabinet du
ministre l'intérieur le directeur du
cabinet du président de la république
sont tous au courant des faits le 2 mai
vous n'êtes saisi que récemment après
que la sphère benalla soit devenue
publique
cette saisine est manifestement légitime
compte tenu de toutes les questions que
vous avez à examiner est il normal d'un
point de vue de bon fonctionnement de
l'administration qu' il ait fallu
attendre que cette affaire reçoivent
toute la publicité qu'elle a reçue pour
que l'inspection générale de la police
nationale est à se pencher sur elle en
tant que chef d'une inspection générale
je ne peux me raccroche écotaxe temps et
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
est éclair
toute personne ayant connu un délit
voilà puisque vous le connaissez par
coeur je ne vais pas vous faire l'injure
de le redire d'autant que je n'ai pas
sous les yeux et je risquerais d'être
d'être imprécise pouvait
saisir l'inspection générale ou faire ou
faire une une déclaration pour procurer
la république je vous remercie madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
madame la directrice
une question un peu similaire mais
formulé quelques différemment vous
recevez donc cette vidéo vos services
reçoivent cette vidéo début mais en
ignorant l'auteur des faits il estime
que s'il s'agit de policiers
il n'est pas de motif pour poursuivre
plus avant en recevant cette vidéo et
connaissant l'auteur des faits c'est à
dire le fait que ce soit un observateur
quelle aurait été la marche à suivre
pour vos services
[Musique]
si nous avions su que
les deux personnes en cause n'était pas
fonctionnaire de police
nous aurions démarré une enquête
judiciaire après avoir rendu compte bien
sûr au parquet et nous aurions doubler
cette enquête judiciaire par une enquête
administrative mais enquête
administrative qui ne pouvaient pour le
coup un pacte et que les fonctionnaires
de police puisque l'inspection générale
est compétente que pour les
fonctionnaires de police